liebe mitbürger anhänger der partei afd
werden zunehmend ausgegrenzt
auch im bundestag bitte schauen sie
nicht weg machen sie mit beim einer
aktion mein freund ist afd
ich zum beispiel bin ab jetzt
integrationspartner für jürgen jürgens
tft abgeordneter hallo jürgen hallo
liebe zuschauer auch das ist deutschland
deutschland sieht nicht nur aus wie ich
das vergessen wir gerne für den jürgen
waren die letzten jahre nicht einfach
immer mehr fremde homo-ehe schwule
dürfen plötzlich lesben heiraten
das in dem jürgen alles viel zu schnell
der jürgen ja das gibt uns aber noch
lange nicht das recht so auf ihn runter
zu gucken in wirklichkeit können wir
ganz viel voneinander lernen
ich habe ihm zum beispiel gezeigt wie
man an halal eine ziege schlachtet und
jürgen hat mir gezeigt
was echte deutsche musik ist
und echtes deutsches essen und vor allem
habe ich dank jürgen erst unser
grundgesetz verstanden zb artikel 4
die freiheit des glaubens und des
religiösen bekenntnisses sind
unverletzlich idiot dachte immer das
gilt für alle
und dann hatten jürgen gesagt nein das
gilt gar nicht für leute wie dich
deswegen wenig das katholisch und lassen
eine beschneidung rückgängig machen das
geht ganz einfach du brauchst nur ein
stück fahrradschlauch dass wir das
machen sie mit beim einer aktion mein
freund ist neuer update
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr schöne aktion